oui
merci au sud de la turquie
l'importante ville portuaire est aussi
une station balnéaire ise pour séduit
historique et son littoral agréable
mahmoud un syrien est arrivé ici il ya
un peu moins d'un mois il ne rêve que
d'une chose repartir
il a payé 6 mille dollars américains
passeur contre la promesse d'atteindre
l'europe
un eldorado machisme là bas il n'y a
aucun problème rien toulouse averti
l'argent n'est pas un problème en oeuvre
il y à la civilisation l'humanité la
liberté c'est le rêve de tous les arabes
marque mode et des centaines d'autres
compagnons d'infortuné ne feront le
trajet sur la mer méditerranée
clandestinement à quelque 25 km des
côtes en eaux internationales
ce bateau les attend ces images nous ont
été fournies par l'intermédiaire d'un
passeur le navire acheter arabe et en
egypte est fin prêt pour le voyage vers
les eaux territoriales italiennes nous
assure-t-on un périple qui devrait durer
environ une semaine sans aucune garantie
de succès confiance pour l'argent que
j'ai mis en consigne pour ma vie mon âme
merci n'est devenue une plaque tournante
du transport illégal de réfugiés vers
l'europe
la turquie accueille plus de 1,5 million
de réfugiés syriens
un marché lucratif pour les nombreux
réseaux de passeurs qui ont pignon sur
rue ici
attar un nom d'emprunt travail pour de
ces réseaux comme le cantal merci de
merci nous avons organisé une trentaine
de passages tout ça sans aucun problème
nous avons de grands bateaux de près de
100 m nous pouvons émettre 500 600
jusqu'à 700 passagers transmis tous ceux
qui sont impliqués dans le trafic
illégal de personnes ici et qui ont
accepté nous parler confidentiellement
insiste la sécurité de leur passage et
distillent leur tient à coeur mais pour
toutes ces affirmations
nous avons aussi rencontré beaucoup de
réfugiés syriens dont l'expérience avec
ces groupes interlope est tout autre
tous et chacun réuni dans cette pièce
ont été floués par des passeurs d'une
façon ou d'une autre
ayad et sa famille et ce croquis pour la
somme de 13 mille dollars
zina elle a frôlé la mort elles n'ont
ils nous ont mis des couteau sous la
gorge ils nous ont tout volé ils nous
ont pris comme des animaux ils nous ont
jetés par dessus bord nous étions dans
l'eau jusqu'ici j'avais mis trois
enfants admet qu'il a fait à ses côtés
soad écoute désemparé le voyage en r la
terrifie mais que peut-elle faire
d'autres de mantel les occidentaux ne
réalise pas la chance qu'ils ont dit
elle une fois dit il sont au chaud dans
leur maison les grands les petits les
ministres les présidents et leurs
enfants de bonne vie alors que nous nous
avons la mort et la misère
une misère qui n'a d'égal que la volonté
des gens de la fuir mais le temps est
venu peuvent bien se rencontrer pour
l'empêcher mais c'est impossible
le passeur est un homme dangereux croyez
moi il va passer sous l'eau s'il le faut
l'ipad mais s'il échoue cette fois
mahmoud essaiera encore et encore
si mario bédard radio canada merci en
tout cas